The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Tools and topics--
this is really the first
part of two modules.
The following module's going
to be Six Sigma basics,
and what I'm going to
talk about in the quality
tools and topics
is going to flow
in from the foundation
for what Earl
is going to talk to you about
in the Six Sigma basics module.
So at the end of this
module, we expect
you to be able to
describe how quality
is essential to lean
in achieving customer
satisfaction.
And secondly, we want you to be
able to use some basic quality
tools, and we're going
to spend about half
of the lecture exploring these
different kinds of tools.
So why do we care about quality?
Always have to start with that--
a lot of times the
cost, of poor quality
is directly measured
in items like this.
It's, how much scrap or
rework do I have on a project?
How many service calls
do I have to make
to fix something that's broken?
What are the costs of fulfilling
a warranty or other concessions
that you have to make
to customers when
your product doesn't work?
But it turns out that the hidden
costs or the indirect costs
of quality can be 2
to 3 times as large
as your direct measured costs.
So if you think the direct
measured costs are large,
really, what your organization
is spending on poor quality
is enormous, because it's
much, much bigger than that.
And they show up in terms
of the excess inventory
that you might need to keep
around, because your processes,
your quality is so poor
over time for employees
to deal with those
poor quality issues--
all the non-value
added and wasted
steps, and queues, and delays
that happen and cost money.
And not the least bit is
the reputation or image
of the organization for
having poor quality.
And sometimes the cost of that
is really quite immeasurable.
So let's start with--
one of the common ways that
people think about adding
quality is with inspection.
But we've already talked a
little bit about inspection
in the course, and how non-value
added inspection really is.
So if you're buying
a car and you
have lots of people
who are inspecting it,
does inspections make
your car go faster?
Does inspection make your
car get better fuel economy?
What else is important
to you about a car?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Safety-- does
inspection make your car safer?
Some of you are nodding.
OK, so some of your
saying no, so there's
some disagreement about if
inspection increases safety.
I think, after the
next three slides,
I will convince you
that inspection does not
make your car safer.
Anything else you
value in your car?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Gas mileage--
so does inspection make
your gas mileage get better?
Probably not-- the
takeaway is inspection
doesn't typically add to what
you, the customer, value.
It may help to make sure that
a bad product doesn't come out
of a factory, out of a
service to get to a customer,
but inspection doesn't
help you actually
build in quality
in the first time,
because inspection is
subject to a lot of problems.
There's different varying
skills of inspectors
and their attention span
at any given point in time.
There's measurement
capability of humans--
varies widely.
And there's
environmental factors
as well that contribute to
inspection having widely
performing characteristics.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
inspection from the point
of view of the owner of a
car, where really, inspection
is part of a system of
the quality of the safety
of our communities.
We are stakeholders
because we own a car
and we have to have it
inspected, but it's not--
it wasn't necessary there.
The inspection--
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Are you talking
about the state-mandated
inspections?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should have clarified.
So I'm thinking about
inspection like you're
at the Ford or the GM plant,
and they're manufacturing a car.
Yep.
So I'll note that
for the future.
Maybe that example's not the
best one to take, but yes--
or think about a factory
making a television.
The fact that there
are inspectors
all along the
assembly line doesn't
mean you get a better
picture quality on your TV,
for example.
Or it doesn't mean
that it costs less.
Cost might be a value
that you have for your TV.
Yeah, state
inspections-- we'll talk
about that in a little bit.
And it turns out, when
state inspections are done,
they're actually not
visually inspecting much.
They're actually
doing inspections
that have instrumentations that
are taking quantitative data.
We do call that
inspection, but what
we mean here is really
visual inspection, eyeballs
on some kind of
part of the process
to make sure that the
product is turned out right.
So just to demonstrate
to you some
of the challenges
involved with inspections,
we have an exercise.
So if you can take
out your folders,
there's an inspection
exercise in there,
and it's a bunch of prose.
So it looks like this.
It is entitled
inspection exercise.
So if you can take
it out and turn
it face down in front of you--
so take your text, flip it over
face down so you don't see it,
and take your pen in
your hand, and get ready.
So the exercise is going to
be in two 30-second sessions.
So your first task
is to find all
of the lowercase or uppercase
Fs on a page of text.
So you are an inspector.
You are the F inspector.
So take out that
inspection exercise.
Turn it face down.
When I say go, you are going
to circle all the lower
and uppercase Fs that you find.
On stop, I want you to
turn your sheet over, OK?
And we're going to
pass it to the right.
So everybody clear?
I say go, you flip your
page over, you circle--
it's important that you circle.
Circle all the Fs,
lower and uppercase.
Ready?
Go.
And stop.
Turn your paper over.
Pass the sheet to the
person on your right.
Yeah, turn it face down.
All right, this is
the second inspection.
So now on the paper,
when you turn it over,
you're going to mark
Xs on all the other Fs
you find that were not
found the first time.
So ready?
You have 30 seconds.
On your mark, get set, go.
And stop.
All right, now, take
the page that you have,
and I want you to
count all of the Fs
that you placed an X
or a circle around.
So tally up all the Fs that you
found on the sheet-- both you
and the person previous to you.
And please make sure you
tally separately the circles
and the Xs.
All right, when you
have tallied your Xs,
I'd like to get the number
of Fs that were circled.
And we're going to
just go around the room
and just shout out the
number of circled Fs
that you have in turn.
I'm going to take them down
here on the computer when
you do this.
And the next one?
AUDIENCE: 31--
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: 31--
oh, that's a record now.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: 36?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: So 36 is a
data point you'd like to add?
Well, that's a pretty
high-quality inspector.
That one definitely wins.
All right, let's go on past two.
So now what I'd like to
know is the number of Xs
that were caught.
10?
10-- OK, great.
All right, so let's take a look.
So this is a graph that shows
us how many Fs we caught
on our first pass
on our second pass.
The average is in the red.
And then we also have
the standard deviation
that's shown, so you can
see the kind of variation
that we have between all of
you highly-qualified inspectors
in the room.
There are still some significant
variation in the number of Fs
that we can catch.
And then the blue column, which
you see displayed in pass 2,
is the projected
average of Fs that
might be caught based on
the percentage of Fs that
was caught on the first
pass and the second pass.
And we could keep
calculating that,
if we made third and
fourth passes, and so on.
AUDIENCE: Is that
average the total number
of Fs that would be caught
within two passes-- so
[INAUDIBLE]?
Or is that--
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
That's total, yes.
So that's not this-- the
number caught on the second.
That's the total.
All right, so now let's go ahead
and look at our summaries here.
So our inspector efficiency
is running around 68%.
All right, so let's take
that inspector efficiency
and then return back
to our graphs here.
So there's our
inspection exercise.
This is a graph that shows
you the impact of inspector
efficiency on escaped quality.
So here on the y-axis, we have
escape defects per million,
and down here on the
x-axis is the number
of consecutive inspectors.
So we had just did
an example with two
consecutive inspectors.
And then here, our
different color lines
represent different levels
of Inspector efficiency.
So 70% is with the red line,
so that's about the line
that our class was on--
68% efficiency--
let's call it 70.
So if we wanted to inspect--
visually inspect
our product down
to one escaped
defect per million,
we have to have more than
11 consecutive inspectors
examining each product.
Do you start to see
how that adds up
to a lot of time for maybe
not the biggest payoff?
You need to have lots
and lots of inspections,
and what did we say
about inspection?
It's non-value added.
It's really a waste
in the process
to do visual inspection.
You want to be able to build
in your quality up front.
You want to have
consistent processes that
deliver the kind of
quality you want,
and not try to
inspect it in later.
So that's just a
motivation for why
we need to think
about quality tools,
and building them
into all the processes
that we use to
accomplish our tasks.
And lean uses a number of them.
They came out of the foundation
of total quality management,
which became really
big in the 1980s,
and also emerged from Japan.
And TQM, as it was
called, was built
on the notion of
customer satisfaction,
and we achieved that
through employee involvement
and continuous improvement.
And then those were all enabled
by focusing on some problem
solving tools, designing
processes, purchasing
efficiently, and thinking about
your product service design,
as well as benchmarking-- going
out and looking at how you're
doing relative to your peers.
But lean, on the concepts
we've looked at in class,
are very much related
to all of these.
We talked about value
stream mapping analysis
as really analyzing the
process design part of it.
We talked, at least yesterday
in the enterprise [INAUDIBLE],,
about lean supply
chains as being the way
that we're looking at
purchasing-- and lean product
development or lean
health care deployment
as a focus on the product
and service design.
And today, in the
module here, we're
going to talk about seven
very common quality tools that
help you address the problem
of troublesome quality.
So the seven basic
quality tools are these.
We'll start with flowcharts.
Then there's some cause
and effect diagrams--
example of which is
shown here on the chart.
Then there's check sheets or
checklists, histograms, Pareto
charts, scatter diagrams.
And then control charts we
won't cover in this module,
but Earl will be covering it
in the next module on Six Sigma
basics.
So stepping right
into our first tool,
flowcharts, examples
of these are
the process maps that
we've already done,
the value stream maps.
A flow chart is which activities
are taking place in sequence,
and the inputs of one flow
into the process become
outputs, which are inputs into
another part of the flow chart.
You also see these commonly
as describing software program
flows, and sometimes
[INAUDIBLE] algorithms
are also described with a
process and a flow chart.
So why are these a quality tool?
There are a number
of reasons why
we think about these is
helping to improve the product
or service quality.
This kind of visual
description that a flow chart
gives you really helps
to improve comprehension
among a large group of people,
because it's laying out
there visually those steps
of the process takes.
And in addition,
it becomes a flow,
and it helps us
make sure that we
are doing each step
of the process that's
required in the
order it's required
and when it's required.
So it becomes that tool for
us to make sure that we've
done the right thing.
It also helps to tie our
outputs to the inputs
of different steps
in the flow chart,
and it can also assist
us with data collection
by helping us understand
where in the process flow
we need to collect and add data.
The second basic quality tool
are cause and effect diagrams.
These are also called
fishbone diagrams,
or Ishikawa diagrams after
the gentleman, Mr. Ishikawa,
who invented these.
And they look a lot
like a fishbone.
And it's a tool for
root cause analysis,
and it's often supported by
using the five Ys exercise.
And this is really to help
you with brainstorming
all the potential
causes or things
that might affect a problem.
So we think about the
problem as being represented
on this horizontal line here,
and then there are usually
six categories of causes to
help with your brainstorming
to try to fill those in.
So you want to think about
causes related to materials,
or causes related to
personnel, or to measurements,
or to methods, or
to the environment--
or external factors--
or to machines.
Now, not every discipline
uses these exact same six,
but they're a great
starting point for most.
And some organizations
and disciplines
have determined their own
particular veining structure
that they like for
their fishbone diagrams.
And then, as you see the
examples I'll show you next,
there are some
primary causes that
relate to materials,
which are typically
shown on the horizontal axes
feeding into these spines.
And then there are
sometimes secondary causes
that feed into a primary cause.
So let me show you an example.
I think that's easier way to
understand how these are used.
So this is an example from
the Institute for Health Care
Improvement, and it's
a cause and effect
diagram about why tests
take so long to get results.
And they've used the
categories for the main causes
of people, environment,
equipment, methods,
and materials.
And so if we wanted to ask,
well, why might materials make
test times take
so long, it might
be because there are lab
supplies as part of materials,
and those lab supplies--
this is a secondary cause
illustration may be
unavailable or they may
be spoiled and no longer good.
We may think about the methods
of why tests take too long.
So what is it about the method
that I'm doing with the test?
Maybe there are too
many people involved.
Maybe there are unnecessary
steps in my method.
So it's not a definitive answer.
This is the brainstorming
tool that you
use to get all of your
thoughts flowing about,
what might be all the potential
causes that contribute
to a particular problem?
All right, another
tool are check sheets,
or a simplified version
of these are checklists.
But a check sheet is
just a structured tool
for collecting data.
So we'll put up for you this
purely hypothetical example
of keeping track of the
instances of quality problems
in our lean academy courses.
So we've identified these
various problems here,
on the column under
problem, and then
we're trying to keep track
of all the instances we see
on Monday, on
Tuesday, on Wednesday,
and we're totaling them
for each of the days
and for each of the instances.
So this helps us know
what kind of data
to collect so we can monitor
the quality of the process
and understand where we might
want to make some improvements.
So I said a simplified version
of this is just a checklist.
Pilots often use these when
they're getting ready to fly.
It's a structured list
of exactly what you're
supposed to be doing, and each
time you accomplish the item,
you check that you've
done it, and then
you place another check
on the other activity.
When my first child was
born and I found myself
in a sleep-deprived state,
like most parents do,
my husband and I were trying to
get out the door with our son,
and we kept forgetting things.
And of course, we were
tired and we really
didn't have the mental capacity
to remember everything,
but both being trained in
lean, we said, you know,
we need a checklist.
And we made a checklist of all
the items he needed-- diapers,
wipes, toys, sippy
cups, food-- whatever--
and we kept them right
next to our door,
and every time we left,
we picked up a checklist--
being brain-dead parents--
and all I had to do
was read it, and say,
did I have it in my bag?
And I checked it off.
And after that, we were
happier, happier families--
so yet another instance
of how lean in the home
is very helpful.
All right, next
tool is a histogram.
So histograms are
typically showing
the frequency of occurrence of
a particular activity or item.
And from this, you can start
to understand a little bit more
about the frequency distribution
that you're seeing--
is this a normally
distributed event,
is it randomly
distributed, and so on.
So we can also use it to see how
a distribution is spread out--
whether it's very
concentrated or very spread.
We can also use histograms
to see changes over time.
We can look at inputs and
outputs in a quantitative way,
and we can also use
histograms to help
us compare what we
need to be doing
to what the customer
requires us to be doing.
And here's where we get to
the sweet part of the lecture,
or about midway through.
And we're going to do an
exercise involving some M&M's.
And I'll ask Q if you can start
to distribute the packages
of M&Ms.
AUDIENCE: It's already done.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Oh, excellent-- they're
here-- great.
AUDIENCE: I hope nobody's
actually eaten them already.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: All right,
so what we'd like you to do is
your bag of M&Ms, but
don't eat them yet.
We want you to count the
number of M&Ms in your bag,
and we'd like you
to do that by color.
So arrange all the
reds, and the blues,
and the greens, and the
yellows, and the browns all
in different categories,
and then count them up.
And what you want to do
then is take the data sheet
that is on your table--
did everybody find
the data sheet
underneath your M&M packages?
Once you have your M&M
bag tallied, please
fill in the data
on the data sheet.
So go to it.
Once your table has
filled in that sheet,
please bring it up from.
All right, if you can direct
your attention up to the front
of the class, so this is a
histogram of the number of M&Ms
that are in all of your bags.
So we have the quantity of M&Ms
that were found in your bags,
and we have the frequency of
occurrence of those particular
M&Ms in your bag.
So let me also ask you to
look around at your table
and look at the color
distributions that you see.
What do you hazard about those?
What do you learn from looking
around at the distributions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: People
are shaking their heads.
What does that mean?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Not many reds?
So maybe red is
expensive to produce.
All right.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: Do you
see an even number of colors?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Not within your bag?
Even if you took a big
sample on your table?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Still not the same?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: And then,
what about the number of M&Ms
that are in a bag--
the same, variable?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Kind of variable--
so if we're thinking about
quality and we're thinking
about the M&M attribute that
you think Mars company--
which is [INAUDIBLE] the
company that makes M&Ms--
what attribute do you
think that they're
applying quality principles
to control the variation of?
So do you think they're
controlling the variation
of the total M&Ms in a bag?
Not with that big
a variation-- how
about the color distribution?
Not that-- so is
it something else?
I won't accept
that as an answer.
What do you think it might be?
AUDIENCE: Weight--
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: Weight--
what does say in your bags?
AUDIENCE: 1.69 ounces--
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
1.69 ounces--
yeah, and that's exactly
what they're controlling.
They're not only saying, you
get about an ounce or about
an ounce and a half.
They're saying, you get
exactly 1.69 ounces of M&Ms
in your bag.
So that's a variable that
they're controlling for.
So we can use a
histogram to learn
a lot about the variations
and about the distributions
that we can see in our
process, in our data.
All right, so let's continue
with another example, a Pareto
chart.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Can we now have it?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Yes, you may now eat.
I forgot to give
you the go-ahead.
Yes, munch away on your M&Ms.
We want the sugar level to raise
up so that you stay active
and functioning for the rest
of the afternoon.
So just to give you maybe a
more serious example of a Pareto
chart, these are causes
leading to emergency department
admissions.
So we start here.
And this is called a Pareto,
because we have the tallest
bar starting in the
front, and working
our way down to lower bars.
And what Pareto charts
do are call our attention
to the things that are
happening the most.
So what this chart
says is pneumonia,
in this particular
emergency department,
is a leading cause
of admissions,
and accounts for almost
25% of those admissions.
And UTIs are next,
urinary tract infections.
So if you wanted to
think about addressing
some of the causes
of admissions,
then you might really look
at these leading categories.
So you might not want to
think so much about cellulitis
or hypertension, because those
aren't your leading folks who
are coming into the ER--
ED.
Maybe you want to think
about these areas.
And similarly, this
line up here tells you
the cumulative percentage, as
you add in each of the columns
as you go along
your Pareto chart.
So your pneumonia and UTI
account for a total percentage
of about 75% of your cases.
Just another example from
the aerospace world-- this
is a similar kind
of Pareto chart,
but done for the root cause
of various discrepancies
on satellites.
This actually
comes from research
that I did as a
master's student.
And we were trying to understand
exactly what this kind of chart
tells us, which is, if
I wanted to eliminate
the waste in my testing,
where do I start?
And we found that the
biggest problems involved
employees or operators.
So there may be issues
of training or skills
here, and that was the
non-satellite-related causes.
And then we called a category
of satellite-related causes,
and it turned out that this
basic design of the satellite
was at fault most of the time.
So if you wanted to try to
eliminate some of those causes,
you might start with
perhaps training,
and then thinking
about design that
might ensure more robust
performance under the testing
conditions.
Next quality tool,
scatter diagrams--
these are just plots of x,
y pairs of numerical data.
And what we can see from
here is whether there's
any kind of correlation
or pattern--
because correlation and
pattern are not the same thing.
Correlation indicates
whether they're
following some kind of straight
line, like they are here.
So this type of data
is correlated data.
We can say that x varies
with y in some relationship
that we can estimate
from the scatterplot.
Or we can look at
scatterplots here
and say, well, there's
really not a terribly strong
correlation between
our x and our y-axis.
The patterns are
not very strong.
It's a very good starting
point for root cause analysis.
If two variables
are related, you
want to think about them
in terms of which one
might be causing the other one.
Keep in mind, correlation
is not causation,
but there's some kind of link
between those two variables.
All right, just to sum up
and try to get ourselves back
on schedule, so
first thing we hope
to prove to you-- that
inspection is just
a very ineffective way to
produce high-quality products
and services.
Sometimes you're going
to have inspections.
Sometimes you're going to
do it, but it's not really
the most effective way.
We then talked about
total quality management
and lean thinking,
and tried to show you
how they're closely
related to each other,
and that they both utilize
some simple structured
quantitative and qualitative
tools to help achieve quality
as a result of applying
the different processes.
We covered seven--
well, actually,
covered six basic quality
tools in this module.
We'll cover one more
in the next module.
But we want you to remember
that capable people are
the most important factor
in achieving quality.
So it's not just having
a better testing machine,
or having a better
design, or other factors,
but it's capable people.